do you ever go off the line diet so no
never never ever ever and I never cheat
because nothing tastes as good as being
healthy feels and the repercussions for
cheating for me are so severe and so
quick that it's just not worth it like
would you eat peanuts if you really like
peanuts if you had a peanut allergy
what if you really liked peanut butter
it's like asking that kind of questions
like well what if you really like fruit
yeah but I get arthritis and my skin
breaks out and then I cry all the time
no fruit tastes that good what I am
going to try right away I've had a
number of theories about this diet over
the years you can check the blog but I
like went down the rabbit hole into
everything especially before I came to
diet I I was looking at everything and
right now my theory is that I have got
extremely severe environmental allergies
and I'm getting cross reactivity in
plant food and I think it kind of makes
sense with pork too because I'm pretty
sure and we just make sure that this is
right
yeah crazy okay okay so this actually
this actually seems like a good theory
and I've um I know the owner of a
pharmaceutical company who's good at
this kind of stuff and he said it makes
sense so I think from being born through
a C-section and being put on antibiotics
under the age of six months as a kid I
think that just spiked my immune system
to react to absolutely everything and
I'm hoping and thinking that my
environmental allergies are so severe
I'm reacting to plant food and this
lines up with my serious sensitivity to
Pork which is like why why would I have
a reaction to Pork all I eat is like
beef and lamb and bison why does pork
give me arthritis if you have a cat
allergy you can have cross reactivity to
Pork I'm so allergic to cats it makes me
hate cats I go into someone's house and
I'm just like oh and they smell weird
and I'm sure if I wasn't allergic to
them I wouldn't feel that way maybe but
um I think my environmental allergies
are so severe I'm going to cross
reactivity to play plant proteins pork
proteins and that's causing just
systemic inflammation and then there's
this hypersensitivity reaction where you
can have if you have leaky gut which can
be caused especially if you're gluten
intolerant your gut is very thin you can
have permeability issues where food
proteins leak into your bloodstream and
then your body starts attacking these
food proteins which they treat like
bacteria or virus they're not supposed
to be in your blood you can say this is
a little like food protein floating
around your blood your body can attach
little antibodies all over it and then
those can start to build up in tissues
if your body can't get rid of them fast
enough if you keep ingesting these Foods
so I think that's kind of what happened
to me combined with this environmental
allergy Theory so say my theory is
correct say I'm so allergic to the
environment which is true I'm so
allergic to like grass mold tree
cockroaches they test you for that dust
mites horses cats dogs anything with fur
other than rabbits not entirely sure why
just just everything which I think is
also why I'm allergic to smoke I'm so
allergic to smoke if I go to a campfire
and then I sleep with the smoke in my
hair I wake up not being able to breathe
the next morning I'm like EpiPen
allergic to the world it's nuts anyway
how do you desensitize yourself from
environmental allergies if you're
allergic to everything well I've come
across a couple of companies that do
sublingual so they take a little bit of
the allergen so say like cat dander tiny
tiny little bit of cat dander and they
put it in glycerin and I don't think I'm
allergic to glycerin and then you put it
under your tongue you put like a drop in
once a day and over a period of one to
two years theoretically this helps or
eliminates 80 percent of people's
environmental allergies everybody should
know about this stuff they used to do
allergy desensitization in shots and you
have to go into the doctor's office
multiple times a week and get shots and
now they have sublingual drops and
they've shown this to help people with
say peanut allergies because kids will
like die from these things they'll hop
on a plane they'll have a peanut allergy
reaction and they'll die this has
happened and they're starting to do
these this sublingual immunotherapy for
kids who have severe food allergies and
I have you know severe soy allergies and
everything else anyway that's my theory
so I'm going to be trying
desensitization therapy through
sublingual drops and I will keep you
guys posted because wouldn't that be
crazy if this was environmental
allergies the whole time that were so
severe that eating plants was giving me
environmental allergies environmental
allergies systemically leading to an
autoimmune disorder
[Music]
thank you